it's Friday and that means it's time for
following the Muller report bars mic
drop moment and to hit 70 sitcoms are
headed back to TV joining us now with
all the details Raymond Arroyo Fox News
contributor in New York Times
bestselling author the brand new will
Wilder book the amulet of power are at
Raymond what were some of the oddest
moments in the media atmosphere
yesterday Laura in the wake of the
Mueller reports some outlets like Rachel
Maddow for instance spent half of her
show just reading the report it was like
Reading Rainbow for the politically
obsessed watch the Russian government
interfered in the 2016 presidential
election in sweeping and systematic
fashion quote the special counsel on
March 18th 2016 the IRA purchased an
advertisement depicting candidate
Clinton and a caption that read in part
himself he requested two members of his
campaign that they needed to figure out
ways to find Clinton's emails no Laura I
really like her readings this is vice
I'm a big advocate of reading aloud
particularly kids you are but Vice took
it a step further they read the entire
report in just under 12 hours Laura and
look at the beautiful pictures they
provided there anyway there were some
pretty dramatic moments Laura once the
report dropped Chris Cuomo and mayor
Giuliani were one for the ages the word
of the day was lie as I want to know if
you will apologize on the part of the
president for denying Russian
interference all along his it and lied
why did she recent live oh why did the I
about it president please stop using a
word lied when you don't know what
you're talking about this was ugly this
went on and on with your friends well
you know when a narrative when you're so
wedded to a narrative and it falls apart
with the report you get this reaction
Joe digenova
popped up on Hill TV and the host there
also said Bill Barr may
Lyde you have no evidence that he lied
and you know it I'm telling you
you said he may have lied what I'm
telling you is that what he said this
today in the press conference is
inconsistent with what's in there that's
not a lie that's okay fine
it's not fine we're on national
television calling the Attorney General
a liar I didn't say that you suggested
it very strongly all right I think we're
done here
I think we are Oh Judah Jennifer brought
out the gloves there was something is
Matt out still reading hmm of which were
sent via encrypted applications without
them being able to track what happened
his name's who that no you brats damn
prosecutors judgment that crimes were
committed but that no charges will be
brought before the president's message
to sessions that he should confine the
Russia investigation to only future
election meddling I think he should go
audiobook all right I have to ask you
about Bill bars press conference because
I think I got starting all these tweets
text why was it contouring what we're
hearing from some of the malcontents why
was it so effective
well bar takes no guff he's very cool
very even he's kind of the George
Foreman of lawyers he takes a punch he
just stands there
watch this exchange he had with CBS's
Paul Reid who challenged him over
whether the president faced an
unprecedented situation during the
Russia probe
[Music]
well is there is there another precedent
for us no okay so unprecedented is an
inaccurate description isn't it okay can
you imagine if Jeff Sessions were here
during this anyway you could sense bars
frustration as this went on as these
reporters asked increasingly ridiculous
questions all leading to this mic drop
moment propriety for you to come out and
sort of just walk somewhere I love the
walk off he doesn't even think about it
do you feel you're spinning this no and
he's gone it's a great monster drop the
accent Mike well some of you may
remember the hit sitcoms all in the
family The Jeffersons
well ABC has announced that they are
airing a live classic episode from each
of those shows with an all-star cast
Woody Harrelson and Marisa Tomei will
play Archie and Edith bunker and Jamie
Foxx is set to move on up and play
George Jefferson
Norman Lear who created these series
along with Jimmy Kimmel are going to be
presiding over this do you believe this
is gonna work Laura I don't like
tinkering with the best and that those
shows or among the best I've ever
produced I conducted the last interview
with Carroll O'Connor and he talked
about why Archie Bunker worked and this
is why I think this new iteration will
not watch you cannot laugh at the
character you're playing
you cannot be aware that he's funny as
an actor you have to play him in tensley
and you have to play him fiercely and
angrily and that's what makes him funny
he was a classic
I think we're afraid of this material
today and I doubt if an actor is going
to play him through I think they'll
comment on him which will not work later
was mad that bunker ended up being so
sympathetic right and people then like
meathead right they didn't like them all
right stifle yourself we're out of time
made it all right next week I'm doing my
Easter thing with a kid yeah I'm filling
in for you Thursday and Friday great we
get Chaffetz and we got Huckabee and you
are Thursday Friday so everybody tuned
in more hot is the whole thing gonna be
Follies it all falls okay great Raymond
thanks so much